We're looking for the hard,
the math for the graphic design for them, for the next ICM.
There were tried many ideas,
and I was personally very inspired by the work of [inaudible] with his three
dimensional object, curved object,
not the interesting geometry with what eventually was selected.
There's more inspired by [inaudible] and she's very simple shapes named
squares, solid colors.
So I took me a while to warm up to this ideas,
but then I realized there's some cool math about squares.
And so I'm going to talk about one today's particular about square tonics.
Like for example, here you have, uh,
the here you can tell the whole plane was just two kinds of squares. So this is,
and you imagine this two squares, and if I just periodically repeated,
this is going to tell the whole, the whole plate,
this is the simplest styling you can make out of squares,
which is not all equal.
And it illustrates something with the Pythagorean theorem.
So the way it works is that think about, so you can either say, you can,
you can take the Steger and, um,
maybe he'd be anchored his at this red dot. And so then they move it. We can be,
you can accurate all the other red dots here in this picture,
but if you connect all this red dot, I'll try my best.
And so then this is that should have been a square. I did this.
You can imagine that's a square. And so what the seller says that you can be,
you can either tell the plan with this,
with this two square or what this one square, repeat it.
And so it has to be the case that the area of these two squares equals to the
area of this big square.
And that's how this is a really Pythagorean theorem because to the CLS, you can,
you can think that this piece is the same as,
so if you want to pick this to squares and move it to inside the yellow square,
then this piece will go here. That piece
will go there and maybe this piece will go over there.
And so this illustration of this pieces,
you can construct either one big square or two small squares.
And that's the a squared plus B squared equals C squared.
A nice illustration.
And this overall tiling is the simplest tiling you can do other than just
squares of just.
Though, than to the square grid. Yeah. That's the simplest.
One, those two different sizes.
Is there anything interesting about their proportion to each other?
The arbitrary? Yeah. So this said, because in, in, in,
in a square plus B squared equals C squared, you can choose a and B.
And same with the tiling. Then it could be a giant square and a small cluster.
Exactly what changes individually is that the size of the smaller square
changes. And so they all the tiling stars, stars kind of waltzing around.
There's something really neat math involved about how you generally think about,
about the square tilings. That's a, maybe I'll explain it here.
So this is a tiling, so it's a profuse of a tonic of a plane by squares.
We're going to represent it like this. There's a lot of plantation here.
I'll explain it in steps. So,
so what we see here is our squares squares are numbered one through 15.
So this is number 10 wide. And then they're horizontal lines. And I,
and the horizontal lines, if it, if it,
if several square shared the same horizontal line,
I consider it as one horizontal line.
I drew them in red and I labeled them from the beginning of the alphabet.
So this is a,
and this is B this line is C and so forth up to don't age.
And there are vertical lines.
The same thing with just if some squares share the same vertical line,
I consider it as a one line. And I labeled it from the end of the alphabet.
So this line is that this is why this is X WVU.
And so now we want to represent this picture as a graph and what will be in the
graph here.
Now you can make a choice and the fact that you can make one choice or the other
choice, it'll be interesting later. So, but now we will choose.
One quick question, where, where did this Thailand come from?
Like I just imagine you can, you can just make it large. Exactly.
This wasn't a special thing, just a random one, just the random.
And so now we're going to think,
now we're going to discuss how you think about topics and gentlemen.
So in particular, you'll see how you can generate a random talent or some more,
something more interesting than this. And so graph is the glare on the plane.
It's a bunch of vertices connected by a bunch of edges.
And since it's in the plane, it also has this faces.
So this is like a face here.
And so what will be the vertices of the vertices will be the red lines actually
in New York city is blue, and it's also lined with subway, but
this, this didn't work out. So the red lines from the diverted, so this is a,
and I put it in at the same height as a humid. So then,
then there's BC D and so forth. And what are the ages?
The ages is when the square square five,
and it has a line at the top and the line, the bottom. So here,
the five is between a and C. And so five is this H here that connects a to C.
And so maybe this square seven, this is girls between C and F.
And so here's this edge seven seat in F. So the,
the vertices are the horizontal lines. The squares are the edges.
And then the, the vertical lines, there are the faces like, like,
like look here. So there's a vertical line. It's surrounded by square seven, 11,
eight, and 12. So we'll look at this X here, seven and 11,
there are seven 11 here, and eight and 12, they're on this,
on the other side of this vertical line. And now the most important thing.
How do you remember the actual size and positions of the squares?
If you look at this graph.
By the way, everyone, I did try to get the professor to use Brown paper,
but he won the fields medal. He gets to do what he wants.
The main thing is that we have to record to record the actual shape of this
picture. And we need to know what is the height?
What is the horizontal, what's the height of each of each horizontal line.
So we need to, there will be some equation on,
so we need to know the height of which like, for example, the height of which C,
which is the vertical coordinate of this horizontal line.
If I know this vertical core in that we know, we know this, this whole picture,
and what is the equation on this, on this height. If we look at the,
the length from here to here,
it's on the one hand is the size of this square with the square four,
plus the size of the square five, you know, the other hand,
the size of the square seven plus the size of the square eight.
So the equation is the size of four claws.
This size five that is equal the size of seven,
the size of eight, but those sizes, what are they?
So the size of the square five is the difference between the height of the,
of the line a and the height of the line C.
So we get the height of a mine is the
height of C plus the same now for five, for the height of B
plus minus, uh, this is one of the bar on paper is good.
So mine is the hightest C,
and that is equal to the height of C minus the height
of, so now this,
this F was the height of C minus the height of the other thing
is deep. And so when we rewrite this,
we get the height of C is one quarter
of the height of the sum of height of all its neighbors.
Come from professors rearranging this, there's just rearranging this equality.
So the equality they call it, it that base, they, what comes from the, the,
the size of so squares that come from the top adapt to the same amount as
decide. This was quite a come from the bottom.
That becomes the equation that the height,
the height of this lot is the average of the height of this four line.
Or if you look at this graph, the value of the function,
and this verdict is the average of the value of dysfunction and all of its
neighbors. So that is, that is called, uh,
such a function is called harmonic.
This is this a very important notion in math.
The result of this discussion is that a square tiling is,
is a graph and the plane together with a harmonic function on this graph,
harmonic function is the one that the value of it,
it each Vertex like the developer here should be the average of the,
of develop all of its neighbors. It's like, it's like if you think of, uh,
maybe people think of, uh, some social analogy where the, when the, the society,
maybe there's a harmony in society,
if what the person has is the average of all the
people he's connected with, and then maybe the society's in harmony or anyways,
harmonic functions are very important in, um,
in everything that has to do with two dimension. So like, like, uh,
any kind of mathematical physics that has to do with two dimensions,
they're important in, in electromagnetism and fluid mechanics and in all, uh,
all, uh, they also just so Kirmani functions,
you can study in the discreet situation like here.
So it's a kind of a graph and,
and something in the function and the purpose of the graph,
or you can study in the continuous and maybe in a continual doing the Brown
paper before we go there, there is, uh, there is a very important notion of,
of which is illustrated in this picture.
There is a very nice notion of you have a graph in the plane.
Then there is a notion of a dual graph. And if you have a chromatic function,
then there is a notion of a conjugate harmonic function. Maybe we'll explain it,
maybe explain with this picture. And so what is the dual graph here?
We made the choice. We made the choice.
We decided the vertices of the graph are the horizontal lines and
edges are the squares, and the phases are the, are the vertical line.
But of course this,
the picture is completely symmetric between the horizontal and the vertical.
If I just look sideways, what was horizontal, that becomes vertical.
And so in this picture in terms of graph,
that means the full of reality for graphs. If you have a graph and the plate,
then you can,
you can introduce a new word graph called duel divergence of the little graph or
the faces of your original graph.
That would be the Vertex of the dual graph and will be another verdict of the
below the graph. And they're connected by an age.
If there's two phases we're sharing can age to begin with. Here's an example.
So what was a phase before it becomes a verdict?
What was an age stays in age and what was a Vertex now becomes a
phase? So this is the issue that is going around the face.
And if you had the harmonic function on the graph,
then there is a related function on the dual graph called the conjugate
harmonic, which in this case, it's just the, so this is again,
very simple to explain, instead of recording the height of the horizontal line,
you record the X scores in it of the vertical lines.
That will be your contract term, Monica. So you say,
this is the age number sentences. The one hit here. And since this is a square,
what we have here is that the change of the function of the high function within
this divert,
this is equal to the change of the height function between the dual verts,
because that was a square. And as the general definition of a, or maybe we'll,
we'll do the rest on the Brown paper.
So professor, if I,
if I got out a ruler and measured all the distances of everything here, like,
you know, to the, to the millimeter, you're saying,
and I could feed them into these equations and everything. Exactly. Yeah,
that'll be exactly.
So it's basically what you've done here is you did a tiling and then you've just
shown me other ways to represent it. Right.
But it's, it's, it's in reality. It's the other way. There's a, they're very,
you can write that interesting graph and then you there'll be, uh, they'll be,
so then, then,
then you can study harmonic functions on this graph and her money functions on
the graph. If you're, if you're trying to tie the whole plane,
you can imagine that the very, very large distances,
the Giro graph may look something like, Whoa, like a plane.
And so your function will look some, you know,
maybe some continuous harmonic function and the, at the infinity. So this,
this relates to, uh,
the relates to the notions of continuous harmonic functioning,
which we'll discuss it on the Brown paper in the second. And so this is,
this is, this is a fun,
this is combinatorial geometric way to think about her money clash.
So those sorts of way to parameterize the perimetry is the scrutiny.
So do people who are trying to come up with tilings, cause sometimes you'll see,
Oh, some someone's come up with a clever new tiling. Are they using.
Very classical? This is, this is, this is very classical,
but this was known to the mathematicians for the longest time.
There's other very serious mathematics goes into figure out how,
if you study some discreet structure, some load such as a square tiling, if, uh,
or some may be, uh, some other combinatorial random structure,
which are discrete and, uh,
how in the very large distance on the various large scale, they will, they will,
uh, they will behave as,
as something we know from the continuum from her manufacturers were first
introduced in the continuum.
And then they studied in like electrostatics electrostatic potential is an
example of harmonic function. People, people studied it for, for what it is.
It's very interesting how this large scale continuous thing can emerge from,
from small scale discrete combinatorial things. And that is,
and that is actually relates to, to some, um,
to some very concrete problems in mathematical physics. There one,
I think mathematical physics try to do is try to connect different scales.
Like for example, we know that the solids or liquids, both of them are,
are really disputed microscopic scale. So there's something really,
something happens on the microscopic sale. At the large scale, we see,
we see [inaudible] of hydrodynamics or other creations of continuous
mathematical physics. And it's challenged sometimes, sometimes.
And these are sometimes very hard one for mathematicians to starting from
microscopic description, justify the, the macroscopic behavior. And one thing,
which is really,
it really helps if you can somehow reduce your microscopic problem or problem
about sacred monic functions because harmonic functions,
they have a really nice,
so if you have a harmonic functions on graphs and the graphs and the graph kind
of approximate something continues by making, becoming denser and denser. Then,
then you know,
the harmonic function discrete one will converge to a harmonic function that
continues now, suppose you have a continuous harmonic fund.
And so we have a function of two variables and function F of X, Y,
and what is it called? Harmonic?
What's the continuous and the look of the property.
We discussed that the value of the function at the new point is actually the
average over its value over all of its maybe some distance neighbors,
or if you can, in fact, average over the disk.
If I take the value at any point X,
Y this is equal to the average of F over this whole disk,
there's a continuous version. And the,
the basic property about harmonic functions in math is something that you prove
in complex analysis. The fact they come in pairs,
they come in pairs is the real and imaginary you're part of in fact,
the complex functional, like for example,
if I take the function of the form X plus I,
which is I as the square root of minus one.
So this is the square root of minus one X plus Y
squared. And then, then by the law of algebra,
I'm going to get X square minus Y squared.
This is the part plus this I w X Y.
And so now it's a theory. No,
not very easy to prove that both of these things are harmonic and moreover
they're conjugate in exactly the same sense as we discussed this, but the graph,
the level set of this functions, this is my function. Yeah.
And this is my function G and what are the levels of Z?
The levels of Judah hyperbolas like that? So this is,
this is a level sense of gee. This is where X,
Y for the constant and what are the levels sets of F level sets of half.
There there go, exactly perpendicular. And so then if I look at the,
at the grade in the graduate and something which goes perpendicular to the level
set, so maybe this is the gradient of G,
and this is the gradient of F they're exactly different something, but this I,
this, I messed up. This is supposed to be exactly the same size.
And they're perpendicular. This is a continuous version where we have here,
the discreet here,
and they just create the two conjugate function where the height of the Curzon,
Tomas and the X coordinate of the vertical ones.
This function changes vertically by a certain amount.
And the other function changes horizontally by exactly the same art.
The gradients go exactly perpendicular. So that's a discreet version of bed. Oh,
that's phenomenal.
So imagine a game with the following rules. Uh, we start with two numbers.
The sum of these numbers.
Will be more than 50 trillion, great mathematical publishment.
You really do things that you would not believe yourself are possible,
and you have to find it within you.
No, I did not get it right. Uh, I, uh, well, you know, you win some,
you lose some, you, they make a bleak, blender
turns out he did not realize.